У навколишніх селах б’ються ПРОТИ чи ЗА перехід церков
з московського патріархату в єдину українську церкву,
а в маленькому селі Сальник на Вінниччині
старенькі жінки ще в грудні виставили агітаторів
з московського патріархату за двері.
Вони почали агітувати, щоб проти української церкви.
А люди всі за українську церкву.
До рукопашної йшли вони. А жінка каже, мовляв,
хлопці йдіть на двір і на дворі будете вирішувати, не в церкві.
Христо-Воздвиженському храму вже майже 400 років
і його духовна громада стала однією з перших на Вінниччині,
яка вирішила приєднатися до Православної церкви України.
При цьому люди до останнього не знали позиції
свого настоятеля отця Георгія, який
в лавах УПЦ Московського патріархату служив 20 років.
Настоятель теж не був впевнений в тому,
яке рішення ухвалить громада.
Тому сам ініціював сільські збори для визначення позиції віруючих,
заявивши про своє рішення піти з УПЦ МП до ПЦУ.
Яперед людьми сказав, що я свій вибір зробив.
А ви, якщо ви залишаєтесь в московському патріархаті,
без ніякої бійні, бійки, прийде другий священик , буде служити.
Отець Георгій зізнається, що рішення про перехід до ПЦУ
він прийняв не лише із солідарності з
митрополитом Вінницьким та Барським Симеоном
одним з двох представників московського патріархату,
які взяли участь воб’єднавчому соборі.
І не лише через події в Україні з часів Майдану.
І навіть не через своє неприйняття ідей "руського міру",
які так чи інакше відстежуються в політиці московського патріархату.
Ще під час навчання в духовній семінарії, у 90-х роках,
він брав участь у протестах на Майдані.
Потім голосував за Віктора Ющенка,
якій обіцяв створити єдину помісну церкву.
Цього отець Георгій хотів завжди.
Мирською мовою він був таким собі відступником.
Навіть кілька років використовував церковну літературу не свого патріархату,
оскільки видавництва МП не могли виконати його вимогу
та надати для служби україномовну літературу.
Чого в вас немаєукраїномовної літератури?
Тобто Євангеліє, требники.
А мені така відповідь: нам не благословляється українською мовою надрукувати.
То я пішов, купив требники філаретівські - Київського патріархату.
Це не те, що я за один день перейшов…
Настоятель ще рік тому, до переходу до ПЦУ, на прохання громади
припинив згадувати у молитвахмосковського патріархаКирила.
Для пані Галини, у якої три сини на війні на Донбасі,
це було принципове питання.
Нещодавно один із хлопців приїздив додому у відпустку.
Він приїхав, я побачила, що в нього порушена психіка.
Він дуже красень був,порушена психіка.
Як ви думаєте, мені можна витримати таке?
В Сальнику мешкає майжетисячажителів.
Рішення настоятеля про перехід до ПЦУ тут не підтримав лише один мешканець,
"за" висловилися 63 члени громади, сільській голова, усі сільські депутати.
Законом вже пізніше було прийняторішення про те,
що має дві третини громадипроголосувати за перехід.
Але, я не знаю, як буде далі.
Ми прийняли рішення до вступу цього закону і думаю,
що наше рішення є законним і легітимним.
Селище Сальник не є релігійно активним.
У храмі всі збираються лише на свята.
По буднях, на вихідні тут максимум 50 людей.
Парафіян з рештою громади єднає патріотизм.
Тут це підкреслюють навіть у деталях.
Тож, більшість радіє переходу до ПЦУ.
Бо в нас, напевно, дружнє село.
Ми дуже раді, що в нас церква українська
і одна з перших перейшла.
Документи про перехід громади до ПЦУ вже передані в облдержадміністрацію.
Тут чекають завершення процедури юридичної реєстрації ПЦУ.
Настоятель зізнається, що два останні місяці
були для нього дуже нелегкими.
В мене з кліроса пішли, псаломщик пішов.
Все так було зроблено серед моїх ближчих людей,
щоб мене зламати через коліно.
Наразі про свій перехід до ПЦУ в Калинівському районі Вінниччини
з двадцятьох священиків заявили поки два.
Отець Георгій впевнений, що його колишні колеги з часом теж перейдуть до ПЦУ.
Адже, на його думку, раніше багато хто не йшов до Київського патріархату
через те, що це була не визнана церква.
Але зі створенням ПЦУ питання канонічності вже знято.